[Music]  sorry to interrupt there's something you  need to see imagine a world where Kerry  Washington is not Olivia Pope I thought  the concept was crazy yeah it's hard to  do but it almost happened because ABC  originally wanted Connie Britton to play  the part you know I was I was not  necessarily surprised creator Shonda  Rhimes revealed the secret in a new  interview with The Hollywood Reporter  turns out the network did not realize  Olivia was a black character at first  quote I didn't know that there hadn't  been a drama series with a leading black  woman for 37 years I can't believe it  it's kind of unbelievable there are so  many shows that don't make it to here so  I'm really grateful of course Carrie has  led the show to great success the 100th  episode airs this Thursday and hey she  stayed humble she told thr quote this  would have been a great role for Connie  Britton  [Music]  you